Hey Thoughty2 here.
So it’s been a week now since time began,
what have you been doing since the dawn of
time?
Oh you didn’t know; time only began last
Thursday.
I know it sounds a bit mental, but can you
prove me wrong?
It may seem unbelievable, but can you honestly
say that it’s not theoretically possible
that everything and everyone you’ve ever
known, your memories, possessions and the
universe itself didn’t just spontaneously
pop into existence this last Thursday?
You have memories before last Thursday, sure,
but how could you prove that all those memories
didn’t come into existence in their current
state at the time of creation, which was,
of course, last Thursday?
This is called “Last Thursdayism” and
there’s a group of people who honestly believe
that the world came into existence last Thursday.
Those people have taken it a little too seriously,
but at it’s core its simply a thought exercise.
Don’t worry, I’m pretty sure, like most
people are that the universe is 13.7 billion
years old, except these people.
But it’s interesting to think about isn’t
it because Last Thursdayism is impossible
to prove wrong.
It doesn’t matter what piece of evidence
you come up with, no matter how clever or
complex it may be, it can simply be explained
away by saying “yeah, but that evidence
only came into existence last Thursday”.
If the research is to be believed, then roughly
25% of Americans believe that the Apollo 11
moon landings were faked.
Detractors cite apparent evidence such as
the American flag was waving in the footage,
but how could it do so when there is no wind
on the moon?
Apparently the whole thing was filmed in a
specially-built sound-stage in Huntsville,
Alabama.
All meticulously directed by Stanley Kubrick.
They also filmed the Apollo 12 mission whilst
they were at it; well they had paid for the
studio time so they didn’t want to waste
it.
The low gravity scenes were faked using hidden
cables to hoist the actors into the air.
And apparently the film has been slowed down
to add to the low-gravity effect, if you speed
up the footage by 2.5 times it shows the astronauts
walking at a pace that would be normal for
Earth’s gravity field.
Conspiracists also argue that no stars are
visible in the sky.
Considering that the moon’s atmosphere is
nowhere near as thick and viscous and Earth’s
it wouldn’t block any light and when standing
on the moon, every star should be visible.
NASA’s excuse was simply that the low quality
of the photography washes out the stars in
the final image.
But some of the photographs taken were of
a higher quality, yet there were still no
stars and much lower quality images have been
taken from Earth that show stars in the sky.
And then there’s this famous image, taken
by Apollo 11 astronauts, showing a moon rock,
but there’s a letter C imprinted on it,
as if it’s a marker for a studio prop, eerie.
Well there you go the moon landing was obviously
faked, or was it?
No, just no.
It feels enticingly romantic to believe in
a conspiracy theory of this magnitude.
The idea that the US government is hiding
such an enormous secret from us seems so much
more interesting than the reality that we
have created the technology to reach the moon
and passed every, scientific, mathematical
and biological barrier required to do so.
That should be the real story here, but conspiracy
theories are simply “sexier” that physics.
So who am I to definitively say the landings
were not faked?
Well an argument should only remain an argument
until evidence presents itself on one side
or the other, that is absolutely irrefutable,
under sufficient scrutiny.
If a piece of evidence cannot be disproven,
then we simply must submit to and accept it.
Until a time comes, if it does, when that
evidence can be disproven.
What am I talking about?
I’m talking about what Armstrong, Collins
and Aldrin left behind, when they visited
that lump of rock out in space.
An hour before they finished their final spacewalk
on the Moon’s surface, they left a mirror
on the ground, but not just any mirror, a
retroreflector.
A normal reflector returns any light at an
angle exactly equal to the angle the light
hit it at.
A retroreflector always returns the light
exactly to the source.
You’ll need a megawatt laser, but if you
shine a laser powerful enough at the exact
spot on the moon where the retroreflector
was placed.
And if you were to set up a detector powerful
enough to detect the returning photons, you
can actually detect the laser being reflected
back at planet Earth from the moon.
Nothing in nature has the reflective properties
to return a laser all the way back to Earth.
Therefore, there has to be a manmade object
on the moon, placed there by somebody.
This experiment has been successfully carried
out many times, with the same positive results.
No stars were visible because the astronauts
were exposing for the light areas of the frame,
the astronauts in the foreground.
If they had have exposed for the blackness
of space, the foreground would have been blown
out with white.
Dynamic range wasn’t as good back then as
it is today, that’s just basic photography.
There’s also the fact that the special effects
technology required to fake a moon landing
did not exist in 1969, it just didn’t.
Nowadays it would be a breeze, but in a strange
irony, in 1969 the human race had invented
the technology to travel through outer space
and land on foreign bodies yet we didn’t
have the technology to realistically fake
it.
CGI wasn’t first used in film until 5 years
later in the 1973 film Westworld.
But forget CGI, the fake footage would have
had to been shot by Mr Kubrick and co on a
high speed film camera, so the footage could
then be slowed down by 2.5 times to imitate
the Moon’s gravitational field.
But here’s the thing, high speed film cameras
didn’t even exist in 1969.
The technology wasn’t there.
It’s one thing shooting film at 30fps, but
shooting at 60fps or above is a whole other
beast technologically.
To put things into perspective, the 1969 Apollo
11 mission was shot on a 10 fps film camera,
that’s how far off the technology was.
NASA may be very smart but they didn’t have
technology from the future.
Over six Apollo missions, 382 kilograms of
moon rocks, pebbles and soil samples were
collected and brought back to Earth.
Totaling 2,200 samples, many of which were
distributed to scientists, universities and
research centres all over the world, including
Russia, yes America gave lunar samples to
their, at the time direct enemy.
Did Russia examine the rocks and announce
that they were simply Earth rocks, accusing
NASA of not actually going to the moon?
No, and if anyone had a motive to disprove
the moon landings it was Russia.
But what about America’s number one conspiracy
theory?
That the 9/11 attacks were an inside job.
Polls show that 54% of Americans believe that
9/11 was orchestrated by the American government
themselves.
They accuse the government of staging the
attacks to provide the grounds for military
strikes in the Middle East.
And the conspiracists have a handful of really
solid and rather convincing pieces of evidence
that supports their theory.
And of course there’s the old “jet fuel
can’t melt steel beams” chestnut.
Roughly an hour after the two planes hit the
north and south towers of the World Trade
Center, both towers collapsed in seconds.
But the way in which they collapsed was peculiar,
they collapsed inwards and fell straight down
in a perfectly vertical fashion, almost as
if it was caused by a controlled demolition,
using a series of well placed thermite explosives
inside the buildings.
Many argue that the temperatures at which
jet fuel burns are nowhere near high enough
to melt the structural steel beams that kept
the towers standing.
Also many eyewitnesses, survivors and emergency
services who were in the tower just before
it collapsed have reported experiencing explosions
seconds before the building fell.
So did the US government plant bombs inside
the building beforehand to try and pass off
a controlled demolition as the result of a
terrorist attack?
Even WTC building 7 which was not hit by a
plane, collapsed a few hours after the attack.
The only damage it sustained was from debris
falling from the twin towers, yet this small
amount of debris somehow managed to level
a steel frame structure.
Towers 3, 4, 5 and 6 received far more damage
from falling debris, yet their structures
remained intact.
In February 2005 a fire started in the Windsor
tower in Madrid, Spain, engulfing the entire
building in flames.
The fire burnt for 24 hours before it was
extinguished, yet it didn’t collapse, it
had to be demolished afterwards.
So how come some relatively small office fires
brought down WTC 7?
Then there are several other major problems.
America has the largest and one of the most
sophisticated air forces in the world, their
F-15 fighter jets can fly at a staggering
3,000 km/h.
The maximum speed of the Boeing 757 passenger
jets that were hijacked is 980 km/h.
And these huge jumbo jets are not exactly
stealthy, they were flying through some of
the world’s most restricted airspace, vastly
off their original course, for up to and hour
and a half.
That kind of behavior doesn’t go unnoticed
by air traffic control.
Yet on the day, the F-15 combat jets, capable
of striking targets the size of a coin from
miles away, using laser guided missiles, failed
to intercept and stop any of the four hijacked
planes used in the attacks.
Not only were the fighter jets scrambled far
too late but many think that they were actually
told to stand down and do nothing, whilst
the attacks unfolded, unimpeded by the military.
The first and second attacks on the twin towers
happened earlier in the day, but a full one
hour and 45 minutes passed between when the
first plane hit the first tower and when flight
77 hit the Pentagon.
Many people believe there was ample time for
military jets to intercept and shoot down
that plane, if they were given the correct
orders, at the correct time, which they weren’t.
I mean it’s not as if this third rogue,
hijacked plane’s intentions weren’t known,
the attack on New York City had been broadcast
on every major news station for almost two
hours by this point, so it’s inexcusable
for the government and military to let the
third attack happen.
But speak to anyone in the world about 9/11
and everybody has their own version of what
they believed happened that day and why.
If you want to dive even deeper then the conspiracies
get even more far fetched, there’s a large
group of people who believe there were no
planes that day.
Yes, that’s right no planes, they insist
what we all saw hit the second tower on television,
was in fact CGI.
I’ll go no further on that.
But for every conspiracist out there, there’s
someone willing to argue against them and
for every piece of evidence that it was an
inside job there’s an equal and opposite
piece of evidence suggesting it was a genuine
terrorist attack.
I’m not here to try and persuade you one
way or the other, there is substantial evidence
out there on both sides of the fence and in
truth, to this very day, nobody apart from
a select few, knows who was behind the tragedies
that day.
But what I do find interesting is why so many
millions of people do vehemently believe in
conspiracy theories.
Wouldn’t it be so much easier to just ignore
the shady irregularities and accept what the
media tells us?
Or maybe it isn’t, in fact I think it’s
quite the opposite.
It’s far easier and more tantilising to
believe in stories than the truth.
The truth requires extensive, dedicated research.
Whereas all it takes for us to believe in
conspiracies is a few pictures taken in the
wrong light or Chinese whispers from a guy
who works at the mall, who knows a woman who
once dated a man who worked for the CIA.
It’s just easier, not to mention far more
interesting.
But what’s the psychology behind this, why
do people so readily rebel against authority
and are so eager to believe in a good old
conspiracy?
Maslow’s Heirachy of Needs was created by
Psychologist Abraham Maslow, it depicts the
five goals that every human must satisfy to
achieve happiness and life satisfaction.
It starts with the most fundamental needs
and each level of the pyramid must be satisfied
before you can pursue the next level.
Physiological needs are the most important,
such as breathing, food, water, sex and sleep.
And next is safety, it says a lot that the
most important of our basic needs after sleep,
food and drink is safety.
We must feel like we’re not in danger and
our brains know it.
Whenever a catastrophe happens our first thought
is of our own safety and then the safety of
our loved ones.
After the event has passes our brains scramble
to try and find a reason, a cause and a perpetrator
behind the event.
We are unable to relax until we know the exact
people and chain of events that led up to
the disaster and that’s because our brains
seek comfort and security.
When our brain experiences fear our amygdala
is activated which in turn activates the parts
of our brain that process information, this
is our brain responding to the fear by attempting
to figure out why the bad thing happened.
It unnerves our most primitive psychological
needs to think that the world is entirely
chaotic and random and at any moment something
terrible could happen that effects us, outbreak
of war, terrorist attack or a leader being
assassinated.
The idea that there is no order or structure
behind all of this and it is just the random
whims of the global machine that is planet
Earth, is a truly terrifying thought to most
people.
Many people would rather believe that an evil
overlord or an omnipotent shady cabal is running
the scene, and orchestrating everything like
a gigantic theatre play, even if they are
lizard men.
It doesn’t matter because it makes us feel
secure, and comforted.
There is certainly a morbid security in the
knowledge that if something terrible happens
at least someone with a modicum of stability
is behind it and it’s not just caused by
random number generation or a rogue group
of religious extremists who can’t be controlled.
And that’s why we believe in conspiracy
theories, because it gives us a reason, an
outlet to blame things upon, it fulfills our
basic need for safety in a really messed up
way.
At some point most of us have believed in
a conspiracy theory in a casual manner, not
really giving it too much thought.
And there’s nothing wrong with that, because
some of them have turned out to be correct,
we’re not always crazy, remember Watergate
and MK-ULTRA?
People sounded crazy believing these things
happened, and then the truth was revealed;
the people were right all along.
But then there’s the other end of the scale
that goes beyond rational-thinking.
We all know of or have encountered at least
one “hardcore conspiracy nut” who believes
that the world is run by a race of shape-shifting
illuminati lizard people who faked the moon
landing and the 9/11 attacks whilst simultaneously
hiding a master race of aliens at area 51
and controlling all our minds with chemtrails
and fluoride in the water, so they can start
a new world order, in which Kanye West is
president and we’re all tracked by microscopic
computer chips inserted into us via vaccines.
What drives someone to be so certain in these
rather outlandish beliefs?
The dangerous thing about strongly believing
in a conspiracy theory is that it slowly shuts
down your pragmatic thinking.
And information or evidence which contradicts
a conspiracy theory can simply be explained
as part of the conspiracy.
“Oh so you think they left mirrors on the
moon, that’s what they want us to think
dude”.
It’s called the backfire effect and it’s
the process that when people are given evidence
against their strongly-held beliefs they instantly
reject the evidence and believe in that thing
more strongly.
Religious people are experts at this, but
we won’t go into that.
The more people argue with conspiracy theorists
the more strongly they believe their conspiracy,
it’s a vicious cycle and research has shown
that if you believe in one conspiracy theory
you’re significantly more likely to believe
in others.
But many conspiracies from history have turned
out to be completely true and who knows what
document will be leaked tomorrow or the next
day, proving a conspiracy to be true that
sounded wildly unbelievable.
Curiosity may have killed the cat but all
the other cats certainly paid attention.
Thanks for watching.
If you enjoyed this video please click here
to support on Patreon,so I can give it to
my illuminati overlords, I mean so I can make
better videos.
Click here to watch another video and if you
haven’t already, don’t forget to subscribe.